let's go next to our caller from the six
four six area code who's calling today
from six four six hi David it's me yes
it is hi I'm Ben I'm from Chappaqua New
York I've been half a mile from the
Clintons as a matter of fact of course
so yeah so I'm 17 years old and I'm very
politically active I really have been
into politics since probably even before
2016 you know my parents and all that
and I've noticed that a lot of other
guys my age come from pre left-wing
families mm-hmm but they've sort of
gotten absorbed into this sort of
libertarian borderline Trump right-wing
ideology based on I feel like of a lot
of the media more independent media such
as michael knowles ben shapiro steven
crowder kent state gun girl Prager you
and I feel like these people have
created this sort of cynicism towards
certain social aspects such as feminism
or LGBT rights and I feel like
personally I've gotten sucked in a
little bit too and I'm worried that this
may actually help Trump win again like
you know I for example in 2016 I was the
guy yelling that Bernie was too far
right but now honestly it's gonna be my
first primary voting and I'm probably
about for Joe Biden I don't see if we
can break these things down a little bit
so what so I take it that now you think
Bernie is too far left you used to think
he was too far right now you think he's
too far left on what issue is Bernie too
far left in your mind with me I feel
like I've gotten absorbed again again I
say I feel like he's turning a different
audience in this election I felt like
was he targeting in 2016 there were in
inner-city voters as opposed to the
country as a whole you know rural middle
American voters that ended up voting for
Trump which is what part of which really
got me and got me into him but so we're
skipping a lot of stuff through
policy do you feel Bernie is targeting
inner-city voters rather than rural
voters what policy I feel like he's now
turning from I think yes he's still a
lot of there's a lot of the old Bernie
in there about it's Wall Street it's
Wall Street but I feel like there's
still a lot of odd Trump's a racist
Trump's a racist as opposed to then
saying that uh as opposed to saying that
if policy is inefficient I feel like
he's trying to get younger millennial
kind of gotten millennial voters really
hepped up as opposed hasn't Bernie been
doing both though I mean hasn't Bernie
been saying this this is this is a thing
that Trump said that's just racist
calling you know Elizabeth Warren
Pocahontas or whatever but then Bernie
seems very policy centric he's talking
about here's why Trump's trade ideas
don't work here's why Trump's ideas on
health care don't work here's how it
from geopolitical in foreign policy
ideas don't work I mean I'm just not
seeing that okay so you said that he's
pointed out that Trump has said racist
things
who hasn't Joe Biden has pointed that
out as well and you say you like Joe
Biden so of course what is it that
Bernie's doing that Joe isn't that you
feel is turning you off another another
thing that I remember access on your
show is his affiliation with Linda
Sarsour and close relationship with AOC
and Johanna mark you know I'm Jewish I
visited Israel it's a very big part of
my identity and I feel that I think I'm
not one of these people that says BDS is
not OK of course it's free speech but
publicly affiliate associating
yourselves with personally I feel at
home are big but I think that then
you're breaking up terribly but listen
if you can still hear me I agree with
you that Bernie can have no association
with Linda Sarsour but I want you to I
want to point out to you because you
know we're examining your beliefs here
your first argument was that you believe
Bernie has
- targeting urban Millennials / rural
voters and you don't like that and when
I asked for examples the one you came up
with is something that Joe Biden also
does and now you're shifting to
something else which is you don't like
Bernie's associations with some people
are you cognizant of the fact that the
first assertion you made you haven't so
far been able to back up with any real
good examples that are unique to Bernie
yeah I I do understand that I feel like
maybe I've just been listening to him
more lately or something
but I don't know I personally back in
2016 I saw him as this sort of European
like socialist and I've just seen him
talk more lately in the last two or
three years about certain issues like
women's rights immigrant rights which
you know I'm all for but if a candidate
is running on those issues hold on a
second then then let me ask you a
question
if I said to you what is the when you
think about Bernie's candidacy what's
the number one issue you associate with
Bernie I mean like problem I have with
him or no no no no the number one
political issue that is the most
important pillar of his platform what
would you say it is I'd say is tackling
big corporations and Wall Street no now
the policy hold on a second I know you
know what it is what's the policy that
is associated with Bernie specifically
that was the the biggest issue for him
in 2016 and remains the biggest issue
which now everybody many people have
come around to agree with him on well
tack no it's healthcare okay I'm giving
you the answer so listen yeah Medicare
for all right this is this is to say
that Bernie's candidacy is based on
women's rights listen Bernie's candidacy
is of course predicated on the idea that
we need to treat people equally under
the law and equality of opportunity and
so on and so forth but Bernie's Bernie
is the in my mind is the healthcare guy
number one and is the inequality and
corporate cronyism guy
number two I I think maybe your your you
know it just seems as though you you
have a bit of a inaccurate perception
maybe of what is you can still not like
Bernie you can still like Biden over
Bernie
I'm just not hearing from you what sound
to me like really well-thought-out
reasons for it and that's what concerns
me okay and to be honest I agree with
you I think it's partially you know that
one person someone a couple weeks ago
said you should interview Hunter Ave
alone you know I was let's just say I
had some issues I won a big award at
school and was screamed at and called a
white sis male and that I want it only
because of that status which okay that's
neither here nor there but that got me
you know sucked into the hunter Avila
den Shapiro and I think that's turned me
a bit cynical on these issues right so
it sounds like my personal experience
that you had you are now projecting onto
Bernie Sanders even though it may not be
based in fact is that possible Ben yeah
it's boss meaning that's human nature
yeah yep yep alright Ben listen I'm glad
that you are willing to hear reason and
to think through these issues I
appreciate you calling me today of
course thank you
alright we'll talk to you again I hope
sorry to everybody I didn't get to that
does it for calls today we will take
calls again and we'll talk to everybody
next week